if your architect hasn't already told  you make sure that you're always  starting your design with a color  palette in mind before you approach your  architect make sure that you always  bring a color palette or a guide an  inspiration a mood board with you so  they know exactly what they need to do  for me personally if somebody comes in  with a hamptons design wanting a  beautiful hamptons home it is very  simple you go with the neutral color  palette so for example all your  claddings could be whites grays mono  toned you can bring in the subtle  textures of beige and then also some  deep rich colors of the ocean of the  blues and the blacks if you really want  to have a small negative pop of color as  i like to call it